oh and welcome so this is not how I
normally look it's allergy season I have
a little bit of overcompensation
happening no hi my name is Grace help
you do not know now you know your life
is different now it's my knee here my
hands on it this just weird hovering
skin thing looks like a rogue scrotum I
wrote them anyway there's a huge
emphasis on self-care right now which I
highly applaud I think is important you
guys know I've taken some time off here
and there in an effort to figure out
what is self-care for me because it's
different for everyone video is about
morning routines nighttime routines are
so interesting to people they just want
to see what other people do make them
seemingly good and I thought I recently
turned 34 you know be Jesus I feel like
I live a leisurely Haggard life it's
not- that's just how I see it
especially when I come back from
traveling and this past weekend I went
away from my birthday I went to Vegas
for two nights and then I went glamping
for a couple night was a very exhausting
experience because when I travel and I
go somewhere I get too excited and then
I push my body to the extreme when I
have to come back to reality I am mad at
everything because I know I did to
myself but it's way easier to take it
out on everything else around me let me
show you a video about how I bounce back
from travel sort of like a morning
routine it's sort of like a hangover
routine when you call a bowel movement
during a morning routine video of
poutine it's already this is like very
charming and relatable as video most of
this might seem like a joke but I'm
telling you this is a very accurate
morning routine basically this is how I
bounce back and also this is just what I
do mostly every morning when I haven't
travelled the day before that's gonna do
it obviously I wake up in a state of
bright-eyed bushy-tailed confusion most
of the time because regardless of
travels I mostly wake up not knowing
like where I am and then occasionally I
have to check if my dog is alive because
sometimes she likes to sleep like she's
been taxidermied and it scares the
actual [ __ ] out of me
are you dead okay you know your eyes
move and when I'm coming back from
traveling I've started to make more of a
point to unpack sooner rather than later
because otherwise it will just sit in my
house like this bag that becomes like
this tumor that I don't deal with and
then when I have to repack for a new
travel scenario I just get so mad at
previous self for not taking five
seconds to start unpacking the bag
there's a lot of symbolism then like a
lot of people I like to Center myself
with my form of meditation then I like
to take a second to stand outside with a
camera on me recording me to like
falsely capture me contemplating life
and what it all means and then I look at
my devil device and I start comparing
myself to the other curated wonderful
lives of the people around me and I feel
like a real deep sense of Darkness and
then I put some food in my system
thankfully in LA we have access to
really quick easy meals area tips all
right didn't film it and then I tidy up
because as an adult I've learned if you
don't you get ants I mean that's kind of
across the board like if you don't keep
it clean like you're gonna get some kind
of infestation you bring the kitchen to
cuter and then I jump back on my devil's
advice and I just thought it
continuously fall down the dark hole of
seeing how great everyone else's lives
look and like how did they get those
filters and like what who's taking those
photos I'm happy for them they seem
happy and so I'm happy for them and
everything Hey
oh man I took a shower
and then I go back outside and I just
think it like does everyone like that in
the morning and then I take my vitamins
and you're gonna think this is like a
shoehorn didn't sponsorship and it was
at first but now this has genuinely
become an actual everyday part of my
what we call routine camera is a company
that makes it like way easier to get
vitamins and supplements and protein
powders that are customized to exactly
like what you want for your body they'll
start resolutions at the beginning of
the year in January but like fall I feel
like is the time when we're all dust off
the shame that we've had for not keeping
those resolutions and now we can start
new so you basically go on their website
you take like a five-minute quiz you
answer questions about your diet your
lifestyle your goals and then based on
your answers they come back to you with
scientifically backed recommendations of
vitamins supplements protein powders etc
and they will send them to you in a very
cute box that is personalized just for
you in tiny cute packets that have your
name on them and have a little quote
that might be inspirational and helpful
to you because what else do you gonna do
stare at your devil device it gives you
at least 30 seconds away from your devil
device I've become obsessed with these I
don't know if you've seen how much
longer my hair has grown in the last
couple of months but I really think it's
because I have a vitamin in here that's
specifically to help my hair grow they
also have vegan and vegetarian
supplements so there is truly something
for everyone they give me this little
pamphlet that explains all of them to me
if I if I decide to read one day I don't
want this to sound like I'm feeding a
Bolshevism this is a company I actually
truly support and I've become very
dependent on this is maybe the
healthiest routine I actually have and
because they've sponsored this video
obviously you can get 25% off your first
purchase actually scratch that they've
decided to give you guys 50% off your
first purchase that's 5-0 50% holy [ __ ]
they're going to take care of calm and
using the promo code grace H again going
to take care of calm and using the promo
code grace eight
I love you you don't just say it back
I'll just internalize it I'll just look
at Instagram and I'll forget all about
it
haha and then I do my hair makeup and
it's a really swell time Wow me then I
get back on my phone and I let like the
whole overwhelm of everyone around me
that's seemingly living a much better
more fulfilling life I'd really get
right into my phone so I can just sort
of like grow and like blossom into
wildly unhealthy thoughts well there you
go
there's my morning routine slash my
hangover routine slash my like coming
back from traveling getting back into a
productive work week routine if you guys
enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up
let me know in the comments down below
what is part of your morning hangover
bounce-back get ready for the week
routines do you have a routine other
than that I don't know
so I just got distracted staring at a
tree and we're back